c'est une scène rarissime qui fait déjà
la une des journaux du monde entier en
direct pendant le journal télévisé le
plus regardé de russie marina aussi à
nico va surgi derrière la présentatrice
pancartes à la main en russie en anglais
elle dénonce la guerre en ukraine et les
mensonges prononcé à l'antenne avant que
le direct ne soit coupée dans une vidéo
préalablement enregistrées elle s'en
prend directement à vladimir poutine
ce qui se passe actuellement en ukraine
est un crime la russie est un pays
agresseur et la responsabilité incombe à
une seule personne vladimir poutine août
l'employée de la chaîne pervyi kanal de
père ukrainien et de mère russe dit
aussi regretter d'avoir participé à la
propagande du kremlin depuis le début de
l'invasion en ukraine tous les médias du
pays ont été verrouillés une loi votée
le 4 mars dernier puni jusqu'à 15 ans de
prison ceux qui diffusent des
informations jugées mensongères sur
l'armée russe parler de guerre peut
désormais constituer un délit
conséquence de nombreux russes ignore ce
qu'il se passe en ukraine c'est l'une
des raisons qui a poussé marina au sia
nico va à passer à l'acte un geste salué
par le président ukrainien volodimir
zelensky
je suis reconnaissant aux russes qui ne
cesse d'essayer de transmettre la vérité
et combattre la désinformation
je pense particulièrement à la femme qui
est entré dans le studio de channel one
avec une affiche contre la guerre
selon les ong au v des infos pour la
défense des droits des manifestants
marina officia nico va a été arrêté pour
sa protestation en direct à la
télévision elle encourt entre 3 et 15
ans de prison